♪♪ Ne laisse pas passer ♪
♪♪ La chance d'être aimé ♪
♪♪ Le coeur devient moins lourd♪
♪♪ Quand on est en amour ♪
♪♪ ♪ ♪
O On retourne en 1984, ce mati;
çaça fait des décennies qu'il
chchante l'amour et le country :
5050 ans de carrière,
3333 albums, une tournée et
unune nouvelle exposition
dodont il nous parle ce matin.
PaPatrick Norman, bonjour.
- - Bonjour.
- - Ça vous rend nostalgique
dede vous revoir comme ça,
ilil y a presque 40 ans?
- - C'est... je les vois souvent
ceces images la à travers mon
trtravail tout ça. Mais c'est...
cece qui me...
cece qui me frappe dans tout ça,
c'c'est que le temps a passé
tetellement vite!
QuQue j'ai un peu de difficultéà
coconcevoir que j'y pu faire
totoutes ces choses-là en l'espe
d'd'une vie, en l'espace d'une
cicinquantaine d'années. Ce sont
cicinq décennies. J'ai fait de
grgrandes rencontres, j'ai fini
avavec des monstres
dodonc des artistes monstres qui
avavaient une carrière mondiale
cocomme ça.
EtEt d'être avec eux, qu'il
n'n'attache un peu d'importance,
çaça m'a toujours encouragé à
popoursuivre dans ce que je
fafaisais. Puis, c'est pour moi.
cece sont les plus beaux souvens
ququ'on puisse me montrer. Et au
mumusée ici, j'ai fait le tour
jujustement hier, je suis venu
fafaire un genre de vol d'oiseax
etet puis, j'ai été touché
tetellement profondément,
vrvraiment, j'étais touché par e
quque j'ai vu, peut-être parce e
jeje les ai vécus ou assimilés
tetellement de souvenirs qui ont
rerefait surface, surtout quand
fafaisait la recherche. Ça fait
plplus d'un an et demi qu'on
trtravail là-dessus, qu'on fouie
dadans le fond des boîtes puis s
titiroirs et qu'on retrouve des
phphotos et qu'on dit : waouh! s
phphotos qu'on n'a pas vues deps
lolongtemps.
- - Oui, c'est ça! Pour expliqur
auaux gens Patrick Norman vous
nonous parlez d'une exposition e
phphotos qui commencent pour
cécélébrer vos 50 de carrière dc
c'c'est un musée qui se trouve à
DrDrummondville, musée de la
phphotographie Desjardins. Chaqe
phphoto que vous avez sélectione
avavec soin puis ça vous a rappé
cecertainement beaucoup de
sosouvenirs.
- - Ces photos ont été bonifiées
avavec toutes les nouvelles
tetechnologies que nous avons
auaujourd'hui. On pourrait prene
dede vieilles photos et ils en
fofont une photo flambant neuve.
EtEt de les revoir comme ça, avc
l'l'impression de profondeur,
ououlala! Ça m'a secoué. Voyons
dodonc! C'est donc bien magnifie
totoutes ces photos.
AlAlors, je partage... la plupat
n'n'ont pas été lus par personn.
JeJe gardais ça chez moi comme
sosouvenir, dans mes archives à
momoi, personnel. Alors, quand n
reressort ça qu'on les met sur e
mumur, encadré et, je vois que
j'j'ai un bon parcours de fait.
- - J'imagine que ça vous a doné
bebeaucoup d'émotion aussi de vr
totout ça.
- - J'ai été secoué aux larmes.
VrVraiment. Oui.
- - Comment ces années, cette ie
dede projet Daly exposé dans un
mumusée, votre carrière, Patrick
NoNorman?
- - C'est sûr que ça ne vient ps
dede moi.
C'C'est le musée qui nous a
apapprochés.
EtEt je me suis dit : comment
s's'amuser? Je ne considère pas
dadans ce créneau la, mais
apaprès qu'on constate la
cacarrière, qu'on a eu, tous les
imimpacts de cette histoire
d'd'amour qui dure depuis... ciq
dédécennies avec le public, avec
l'l'auditoire, c'est quand même.
c'c'est à souligner, je pense.
EtEt puis c'est avec une grande,
grgrande humilité que j'ai...
ququand j'ai terminé le tour du
mumusée, j'étais aux larmes et
j'j'acceptais vraiment, je me
rerevois encore hier j'étais d'e
grgrande humilité accepter tout
cecela. Et c'est un grand bonhe.
C'C'est une façon de souligner n
trtravail que j'ai pu faire à
trtravers toutes ces années-là.
- - Ça va être un grand bonheur
popour le public aussi de pouvor
y y aller.
- - Extraordinaire. Vraiment.
- - On part de votre carrière ms
l'l'exposition photos nous plone
auaussi dans un demi-siècle de
l'l'histoire de la chanson couny
auaussi parce que vous faites
paparti intégrante en fait du
cocountry, de son histoire, de a
cuculture.
- - Bien, j'ai rentré... d'antan
jeje ne considérais pas comme un
arartiste country. Je me
coconsidérais comme un chanteur,
guguitariste, qui sa musique fae
dede la bonne musique autant que
popossible. Et je me considérais
papas... je vais faire juste du
cocountry. J'ai toujours été das
dedes groupes où on faisait des
cocovers, on faisait
d'd'réinterprétation de chanson
dedes Beatles, autant que de
ChChicago, du rythm 'n blues.
J'J'ai toujours fait la musique
quque j'aime moins parce que la
mumusique que ce soit du country
auau jazz, quand elle est bonne,
elelle est bonne la musique.
JeJe suis rentré dans la porte u
cocountry parce que j'ai été un
pepetit peu et assez par l'élite
auau début de ma carrière. On ne
meme prenait plus ou moins au
sésérieux.
MaMais j'ai persisté puis je me
didisais : il n'y a personne qui
pepeut m'enlever le bonheur que
j'j'ai à jouer, à faire de la
mumusique, la joue de la guitar.
AlAlors je continue quand même,
sasans avoir le désir de percer.
CeCe n'était pas ma motivation.e
n'n'était pas d'être connu ou...
jeje voulais tout simplement fae
cece métier-là que j'avais en
ttête.
- - Vous avez bien fait de
popoursuivre et persévérer. Vous
avavez annoncé votre retraite
apaprès une tournée d'adieu qui
esest en cours, une tournée qui
s's'intitule Si on y allaité
vovotre tournée n'est pas
teterminée.
- - Elle débute à peine. Elle a
dédébuté en 2022 parce que touta
étété des sens et partir en 2020
etet j'enregistrais mon album en
202019 alors que je souligne 50
anans de carrière. Je suis alléà
NaNashville parce que je voulais
meme payer un bel album avec les
memeilleurs musiciens pour mon
ananniversairere, les meilleursr
lelesquels je pouvais mettre la
mamain. Il y avait Brian Sutent,
PaPat Rolland... des noms que vs
nene connaissez peut-être pas ms
auaussitôt vous mentionnez ce n-
llà, autour de vous ou jeunes
mumusiciens ils se disent :! Je
sosors ton album! C'était des
réréactions comme ça que j'avaià
chchaque fois que je l'annonçai.
CÇa fait que...
jeje voulais arriver à quelque
chchose.
DoDonc oui, la tournée qui
cocommence et qui a été mise
pependant deux ans sur la glace.
EtEt puis là, ma tournée commene
àà peine. Et je me dis, moi si e
meme fie à mes anciennes tournés
çaça dure 3,4 ans et parfois mêe
cicinq ans avec les supplémentae
etet tout ça, ça s'étale sur
plplusieurs années. Alors je me
susuis dit : je viens d'avoir 75
anans. Je vais être prêt de 80
anans. Est-ce que je vais être n
trtrain de me pencher sur une
nonouvelle tournée? Et peut-être
esest-ce que je serais encore
cacapable de me pencher,
prpremièrement, rendu à 80.
- - Mais vous avez l'air très en
foforme. En tout cas.
- - Je suis dans le moment
prprésent. Regarde ça, ça va bi.
- - En profiter pour aller voir
vovos spectacles dans les
prprochaines années, donc cette
totournée qui commence à peine
fifinalement. Et puis, on va alr
vovoir cette exposition musée de
lala photographie Desjardins à
DrDrummondville. C'est jusqu'au9
dédécembre prochain. Patrick
NoNorman, merci infiniment d'avr
étété là. Merci beaucoup